what's your like finishing move do you
have like a finishing I got a [ __ ] down
I have more finishing techniques than
anybody ever because I can stand both
stances and do everything from both
stances and I have I have just as much
power my left hand is in my right hand
and my like everything's just the sugar
show me who it is we it is it's [ __ ]
sweet and I thought I've had a lot of
sweet finishes I don't know if you've
seen the one where I had kicked that do
it yeah that one that one's one of my
all time for that's what I was really
looking for I thought I was gonna catch
Eddie with that because his hands were
so low I thought was gonna catch him
with something spinning but he got a
fights like he's for most like the 1,800
or something you know he comes here like
it's got a texture yeah yeah he was the
nicest [ __ ] - I'll admit I felt
bad knocking him out as he was
fluttering down yeah yeah does that
happen sometimes is there times where
you get in there and because sometimes
like I'll even notice like just talking
to friends of mine who were in this fort
even just talking a friend of mine you
were in the sport oh wow yeah drop him
with my left hand
[ __ ] yeah and now that was a couple
years ago but another walk-off you think
he could have gotten you how you think
if they would have given him you know
left-handed ink you see how guys ever
pretend to be out I bet they do this
dink oh yeah no I killed him basically
no yeah they that I on couteau laba
fight verse Mega Man he was kind of
acting like he was yeah and then they
they stopped the fight I believe that I
believe that its price scary getting
rock and you're like I just get me out
of here yeah and you can't climb out of
the top right that would be sweet if
someone did that that would be [ __ ]
sweet but you can't do it you don't put
a top on it no they they probably do you
know dqu or whatever but you ever
getting [ __ ] up I'm dipping take a dip
in
now can you legally climb on to the top
and jump off a ladder you can oh I see I
don't know if you can't grab inside the
fence but you could kind of run up the
cage probably but I see that's another
finish we got somewhere locked in like
is a cage kick like I don't know Anthony
Pettis hit that on Benson but he didn't
finish him
there's not really been any sweet
finishes jumping off the cage right and
and we definitely could could land
something like that soon yeah because I
want to know how sweet the sugar show
can get yeah I wanna see make disappear
no I can't do that we're just getting
started like I'm 25 and and I gotta
easily another 10 years yeah you know
but the way I eat and the way I train
and the way I take care of my body I'm
still gonna be I think 36 37 38 I'm
still gonna be [ __ ] good yeah so I
plan on being in this sport for a long
time and getting a lot of [ __ ] sweet
finishes so when you're out there we
know whenever you whenever you get in
into the end of the Octagon do you think
about like are you already kind of
thinking about the finish as the fight
goes on if it starts to feel comfortable
to you start to think like oh I can
finish this right now but I'm gonna wait
a minute does that ever kind of happen
or it's not like there's too much
intensity in that last fight when I hit
him with that body kick the spinning
body kick I've dropped a lot of people
with that and that [ __ ] was so
tough he tried toughing it out if you
get have you been hitting the liver hard
he just paralyzed and bro I still
[ __ ] every time I eat a snicker my
[ __ ] body hurts I learned it but he
still tried like after I landed that I'm
taking this dude out I knew I was gonna
take him out um because of that just
hitting someone with that shot is so
dangerous and so powerful and I've
landed it so many times and at that
point you start to feel like a hunter at
that point yeah I felt like okay I'm
getting this dude out of here but I
wanted that spin kick I missed it barely
because I hit him with the left body
kicked deep and I threw a right right
hook and it landed hard and then I
switched stances and threw a spinning
kick that's what I wanted for the finish
but that's in that moment I knew I was
about to get him out of there that's why
I spun know what I tried to take his
[ __ ] head off you spun myself around
um but I knew I had him hurt and I did
think okay how am I gonna finish this
dude and that's why I wanted that spin
kick bad but then it missed and I was
like I don't want to gas myself out just
dinked him
yeah I've been good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you could watch could be way
better what if you watch a video right
now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one